[Music]
Phase Apex one of the founders of phase
who amassed over 6 million subscribers
on YouTube many of us love this content
until he deleted all his videos and
seemingly disappeared overnight while
two years later we have him back for an
exclusive in-person interview stay tuned
what is something you wish people knew
about you well lie I don't know how I
would have survived the last couple
years if I wasn't mostly me too man time
for me it's a way of life life's not
complete without even phase the help
with like Ramadan if you're trying to
like go fundraise or something like they
get behind it you don't even know what
you're talking about you're out here the
three Muslims like you guys are just
doing bad he had 300 million dollars he
lost it all really like alhamdulillah
like a billion views on my channel and
I'm like the music the cursing making
fun of kids he said like kids out of
school are making fun of him because
they saw him in the clip or something I
was like oh man oh my God I never
thought about that so I think that
scarred me why are you trying to end I'm
having fun here let's keep going
today I am blessed with the opportunity
to host our brother FaZe Apex
how are you thank you for having me I'm
blessed not sure the pleasure is ours
man thank you so
growing up as a Muslim in Phase I know
he spoke about this a few times but I'm
really curious and I think you know
people are curious as well you haven't
posted in like two years and stuff so we
don't know much about you know yeah Apex
but yeah what was it like growing up as
a Muslim the faith Clan just normal like
I like I said I joined phase when I was
14. yeah um I spoke about it before but
basically when I first joined I was like
a huge fan for like a year as I found
faceland yeah and there was someone at
the time well I don't want a name but
like he was like the top FaZe member
like by far
um you know I always use this comparison
but imagine you grew up watching like
LeBron right and you join the Lakers
yeah okay and then you get to play with
LeBron right wow that was basically me
right in my world that I was in as a 14
year old and the first like one of the
first conversations I had with the
LeBron of FaZe Clan at that time
he asked me what my name was okay
because a lot of people that have
watched me now I've never I never say I
never talked about my name like I never
said my name online I never talked about
myself personally for a lot of reasons
and we can get into it but this
experience he asked me what my name was
then he started like laughing like
crazy making fun of me he's like you're
like you're Arab and you're a Muslim I
was like yeah and he's like does your
mom wear that scarf on her head and I
was like yeah and he's like cracking up
screaming laughing him and another guy
oh my God and I was just like shocked
again this is like my idol at the time
yeah so I just remember like I was I was
like 14. I like turned off my Xbox and
it was just like shook like like
actually like I just remember I've not I
think I've ever felt like that again in
my life the way I felt so I think that
like scarred me and I didn't even
realize for a long time but like for so
many years I was like it's terrified of
people knowing my name because of that
and stuff like that and you know there's
like a lot of hackers in in gaming
so there's a lot of people that were
like online like terrorizers like they
would come at us and like oh my God ah
just it was like it would be like
we're little kids you know what I'm
saying so we'd literally be shaking when
you get a DM from specific people and he
would be like so I got hacked at some
point too
and like
it was bad like everything got hacked
you know they're posting stuff on my
Instagram that was bad they were
emailing people my teachers at school at
the time I was in like Community College
it was really bad so like you know
um I mean that's that's partially why I
don't share much private information
over the years but the being Muslim part
it started with that little I guess you
could call it bullying right yeah
whatever you want to call it that
happened and then um yeah so like I was
just to myself about being Muslim and
stuff being Palestinian I never talked
about it until um
couple years ago a lot of people kind of
speculated like there's like a video
when I moved in like 2017 we moved into
the house here and yeah there was like a
video where someone's like Phase Apex is
Palestinian because they like in one of
my Vlogs I had my keychain and I had a
Palestinian flag oh yeah so if you were
like like freeze framing like slowing it
down zooming in again I never talked
about it and then like to be honest
Habib right after Habib like went on his
tear in the UFC yeah and he you know he
just unapologetically Muslim and like
I'm like you know hit me I was like what
am I like embarrassed about or not
embarrassed but what am I like like I'm
proud you know I'm probably Muslim and
Palestinian so that's when I started
kind of publicly posting about it so you
know the guy the guy that did that when
I was 14 right uh he definitely had a
lasting impact and then just like the
culture also like anyone that grew up in
America I'm sure in Canada it's the same
thing yeah you get a lot of comments
right when you're a little kid too about
like you get called terrorists and stuff
and you're just like what yeah what am I
what is this what are you even talking
about so
you grow up with that and you know as
you get older you realize this is like
you know something you're proud of so
hamdullah
um just to answer your question a little
farther to after I started posting like
a lot of people are like like
masha'allah like I'm so glad you came to
Islam and stuff I'm like no like I was
always Muslim like I was always praying
and stuff I just didn't do anything
publicly yeah so even when I lived in
New York and the New York house with
other guys like I would pray in my room
like nobody maybe knew at the time even
them I didn't really talk about it with
them like they know that I don't drink
I'm not gonna smoke I'm not gonna do
like certain things but um it was I was
always you know practicing and in the
background just doing my thing until the
last couple years now like even a phase
like you know they'll post every like
read and like they'll help with like
Ramadan if I'm trying to like a
fundraise or something like they get
behind it so you know the last couple
years Islam has been a people have been
more like I don't know like if anything
now it's like the opposite like a lot of
people like have a respect for Islam
yeah yeah yeah so it's definitely
changed A lot's changed I'm in the lab
but yeah that's good I mean think about
it like the even the video game you and
I were playing modifier too yeah one of
the enemies was were Muslims you know
they like yell something in Arabic and
there's so many Arabic words yeah I'll
go around the map and I'll be reading
the graffiti yeah honestly this is like
it just says like souk like Market in
Arabic and you're like yeah they're just
Counter-Strike too it's the same yeah oh
yeah all the games it's like it's
literally it's like it's so bad yeah
yeah it's just like oh whatever man but
yeah yeah I mean it's something it's
something definitely that we had to deal
with and I think it definitely it's
gotten better more recently yeah I think
it's because people are are afraid
there's a huge castle culture going on
right now part of that is like being
islamophobic people don't want to be
islamophobic yeah except for the people
who do yeah yeah yeah so that's that's
the biggest for everything right so
there's people that they don't care
they're not gonna stand down and the way
they think about anything but yeah it's
definitely shifted a lot you know in
general I think like everyone's the way
people interact with each other in
general has changed yeah but uh yeah
it's something interesting time for sure
yeah yeah I think on a lighter note
though uh you mentioned two years ago
that one of your fellow phase members
accepted Islam yeah all right so what
was it like seeing one of your peers
except Islam yeah it was uh it was very
interesting he actually grew up in like
a Muslim background like when he was a
kid he was practicing with some people
he was close to that were Muslim didn't
act like it kind of like influence you
know a lot of people have these bad
experiences when they have like Muslim
family members or friends that like
preach a certain way and they live a
completely different lifestyle and turns
people off yeah yeah I think he had some
bad experiences and like bad friends oh
yeah yeah so when I met him and he
actually became friends with my Muslim
friends like when he he'd hang out like
he would see the positive stuff in his
time you know what I'm saying like we
all like everyone no like no one's
forcing anything upon each other like we
get up and like we'll pray while we're
hanging out we'll go back to normal like
he was shocked to see like normal in his
eyes normal Muslims right because most
people are like like to be strict and
you know like the old-fashioned way that
never works for anyone right forceful
like not practicing what you preach all
that stuff but yeah so after a while um
yeah he had a you know his own life
circumstances that kind of opened his
eyes and made him look alive differently
and yeah we spoke a lot about it over a
week couple weeks and yeah he decided to
go to the he came with me to the my the
message I grew up at and yeah yeah he
accepted that's amazing yeah let me get
you know guide him always inshallah I
mean all of us yeah I mean and is he
still is he still keeping that private
uh yeah I'm not honestly uh I'm not
really sure like
haven't
we haven't spoke too much about you know
like there's this like fine line of like
not trying to push also and like yeah so
yeah but I think so I mean he hasn't
said anything publicly but yeah yeah
I mean yeah I mean I mean two years ago
he posted a video uh explaining why you
deleted all the videos of your channel
yeah and um I believe also in that video
you mentioned you want to make more
positive content yeah uh recently I
think two three months ago he put out
another video both the one from two
years ago and the one from two months
ago the morning charity work yeah do you
plan on posting more on your Channel or
or have you retired
uh yeah so at the moment I plan on
posting again I never thought I would
uh but you know for many reasons I
decided I'm probably gonna start posting
again yeah I'm not sure exactly what the
content will be yet I've gone back and
forth a little in my head whether I'll
just go back to gaming or I might just
even do a podcast a type setup yeah a
little different but I same idea yeah
I'm not 100 sure I'm like kind of like
in a weird
um stage right now
um you know phase I'm sure we'll get
into it a little more there's been a lot
going on the last couple years yeah and
it's left me kind of in a confused state
of like what I should do right now so I
think I will be posting I think so
inshallah
um probably I don't know what exactly
but
um the plan is that inshallah to post
inshallah but um yeah
um I did take down all my videos I
privated all of them a lot of people
tweet at me about it and I mentioned in
the video
um people always asking me I'm like dude
just watch the video but not you I mean
this is a podcast but yeah you know I
did YouTube like I said since I was 14
years old yeah
um and basically you know alhamdulillah
like it was always gaming content I
never did anything like
you know in my opinion at the time I
never like I was always conscious of
what the content I was making so I never
like did any like gambling I never did
anything you know like clearly Haram
yeah but as I got older
you know I realized like
music and stuff I used to have a lot of
different music in my videos like
editing oh yeah I used to curse a lot in
my videos I used to do like reaction
videos well you know how reaction videos
are it's like 90 time you're just kind
of making fun of random people yeah yeah
and like so like as I got older actually
some kid emailed me one day I used to
make these videos called try not to
cringe right because you know that's
just internet no that was like the thing
back then yeah exactly yeah but like you
know when you're making content like
that like you don't realize sometimes
yeah I know it sounds crazy right but
like especially when you're like you
know about the you like when you're in
the YouTube mode you're just thinking
what's the next thing I could do yeah
and you're not really thinking of like
the consequences and stuff I'm not you
know I'm not acting like it's the
biggest thing in the world but like it
definitely is I feel really I still feel
bad well and I realize there's so many
more kids that this might have happened
to but there's a random kid I reacted to
a clip
and I guess like he emailed me and he
said like kids at a school are making
fun of him because they saw him in the
clip or something I was like oh man oh
my God I never thought about that I
never thought about that until it's
heartbreaking yeah and I felt so bad and
I was like I was like how do I make it
up to this kit like yeah like I don't I
just remember I emailed them and I'm
like I like I deleted it and I'm like I
told I apologize to the kiddo but the
kid was like it's all good you know then
I'm like okay this is one kid there may
be hundreds of and I never thought about
never never thought about that and then
I started like really thinking deeper
and I'm like a dude like I have
thousands of videos like I had over like
a billion views on my channel and I'm
like the music the cursing like making
fun of kids all this stuff I'm like oh
man like there's probably so many
things that I did wrong that I didn't
realize was wrong at the time yeah and
like uh it was just you know I got
started freaking out like I'm gonna be
honest like I had like a little little
freak out and I was like okay and I sent
an email to like
four different uh imams or like shoe and
I was like okay listen this is what
happened like it's all you know it's all
my money get like Haram like I'm
starting to think of like worst case
scenario and you know the device that
every one of them gave me was like just
take down the worst videos
um you know donate some of your money to
like purify your wealth obviously if
there is any Haram in it try to do good
with your platform instead stuff like
that right yeah so I was like okay
and then in my head I'm like okay I'm
gonna take down the bad videos I need to
just go through I had like 2 000 videos
yeah and I kept putting it off kept
putting it off kept putting it off like
they made me feel relieved right yeah
but at the same time like I kept putting
off so one day I was like all right I'm
just I was like forget about it like I
don't I'm not gonna go down on what's
the worst video I'm like these all
probably have some form of this so I'm
just like I'm taking them all down I
just don't even want to think about it
yeah and how did I honestly felt like a
huge weight lifted off my chest when I
did that and then yeah that's why I've
done that almost not what you know like
it was a good reminder and push to do it
I've always wanted to do more and again
since Habib since all that stuff like it
lined up where like I want to use my
platforms for good anyways so like
that's what that's what the story is of
why I did that and you know
alhamdulillah that's why like now if I
was to continue making content like I
know I know my checklist of what I'm not
doing yeah um and it's actually it's
pretty it's pretty crazy there's a lot
of things like even reaction videos like
I wanted to make her maybe reaction
videos again but like yeah and there's a
lot of videos of people dressed on a you
know if you're gonna react like viral
Clips like a lot of the times there's
just gonna be people that are not
dressed appropriately and stuff like
that and I'm just like
I started questioning I'm now at a point
on my questioning everything like any
affordable content I make like I don't
want to put anything bad in it and I was
there was an eye in the Quran that I saw
that like that that triggered all of
this and it's basically like if you have
any share in good you'll get the reward
and if you have any sharing bad you will
get I saw that and I was just like okay
and then I hit you know that whole
everything I just mentioned happened and
now I'm just very cautious I just don't
even want to mess with like anything
borderline gray area so inshallah Allah
makes it easy but yeah so that's why if
I was to start anything
it's probably going to be gaming because
you know yeah I can control it there's
nothing you know and and then or a
podcast and I can just sit in if the
guest says anything bad
yeah yeah
bro I think honestly a podcast would be
sick yeah I really think you do The
Phase Apex podcast whatever you want but
yeah I'm thinking I'm thinking about it
inshallah I think uh can bring a unique
perspective because like I know all
these guys that live through similar
things as me and like nobody really
talks about it so yeah there's a lot of
interesting things you know and I uh
that's part of the reason we started our
podcast we're like okay we're three
young guys we you know inshallah tried
to be religious you don't see a lot of
that these days yeah yeah so people need
to know that you could be young you can
live in the west and you can still
practice your religion yeah yeah yeah
you don't have to like be on one extreme
or the other yeah I I actually think
that it has helped inshallah a lot of
people so may Allah you know allow it to
and accept it from us yeah but so I was
gonna ask if it was difficult to walk
away from a channel uh with six million
Subs but it almost feels like it was
difficult to stay yeah you know at that
time when I did this took all my videos
down like I wasn't really making content
actively anymore anyway so since like
2017 yeah uh 2018 I kind of paused on
content and I you know when FaZe Clan
continued to grow we got like an office
space a lot of drama happened from day
one uh but like at the time basically we
had a guy that was running the company
who was like siphoning money out the
back to his family members and stuff uh
so he got caught he got kicked out and
then like someone had needed to step in
right so I was like all right you know
I'm cool with taking a break from
content because I've been you know I was
doing at that point for like seven years
every day so I was like already like
burnt out on like you know the idea of
making certain types of content and so
it was like things lined up I went in
the office and I started really focusing
on building the business and like the
brand and helping everybody else you
know
um and then I I was doing on and off
YouTube uh since then in 2018 and 19 and
20. yeah um so you know I didn't this
was after all of that so at the time
when I did that
I didn't even care like about that
content like there's part of me that's
like oh I love watching it's nostalgic
and like people love it like I feel bad
because there's so many kids that are
like yeah man I want to watch those
videos that we used to watch and I'm
like I know man I'm sorry but I love you
but I'm not I'm not but I'm not I'm not
racking up bad Deeds for no reason
anymore but no but like uh it wasn't
tough to to do that at all but like um I
look back though now and like I wish I
and I have regrets not regrets but I
have like you know
if I can go back and teach myself I
wouldn't I would have probably balanced
that a little more and continued and
like you know you can always look back
and and
realize how good certain things were and
yeah but you know so I regret I don't
regret walking away in the sense of like
deleting or privating all those videos
but
if I have like any regret I guess you
could say it's not being not have like
continued actively making content at the
same time
um because it was you know it was my job
and it was it was a way to just build uh
my future and if like so I I did go on
an extreme where I was like all right
I'm gonna kick all the content to the
side and like focus on the business but
like I should have balanced it more uh
for myself but alhamdulillah I mean you
solve the channel right so yeah yeah
whenever you're ready
there's people waiting we'll see you
know how I I haven't posted in years so
I have a video recorded actually like a
like uh I'm back on YouTube video really
yeah once you do record it record it
like a week or two ago oh wow because
like I told you I've been thinking about
it yeah I just wasn't sure then what
I've been waiting to post this I'm like
I don't want to push until I'm ready
like I have the next three I recorded a
couple videos I recorded some like you
know Black Ops 2 I went back on Xbox
360. yeah because they did the battle
pass thing yeah yeah I bought Xbox 360
or I haven't actually I bought a new
disc I made some like I made a video it
was fun yeah I've been playing I played
fortnite I mean I recorded a couple
videos but like I'm looking for editors
and like yeah to get it like into a
system before I started but even since
then again like I told you I'm like I
don't know if I'm gonna do this or if
I'm gonna just do a putter yeah so I'm
gonna figure it out but that video will
come out and I and I kind of talk about
what we just talked about in the video
like my light like where I've been kind
of yeah and then yeah I'm just gonna
just go with it but um yeah we'll see
that's amazing man I honestly think a
lot of people a lot of people really
appreciate that you know if you came
back yeah
um a lot of people love your content man
even me like you mentioned you've seen a
few clips of mine but like I was watch
watching you and and Nord in and like
all the phase guys growing up man uh
it's so nostalgic it's just as nostalgic
as monographer two is for me yeah and
that's extremely Nostalgia bro I I
pulled up to Best Buy with like I'm
Canadian so like you know make fun of me
like loonies and toonies and like all
these coins you can't rip those you can
you know because Norden right he's
Canadian so oh yeah I know I know a
little too much about Canadian culture
because these guys are Canadian he's one
of my best friends so he is one of my
best friends but I remember they'd
always talk about you can't rip the
money and I went one time to Canada oh
the new the new bill yeah it's like
plastic yeah it's like impossible I wish
I had some I saw the camera but Tim
Hortons and poutine oh my god I've never
been a fan of poutine but Tim Hortons I
missed the ice cap so much I've been to
California for like three months and
like I miss the ice caps man anyway
going back in four days sorry cut you
off but the Canadian I just know these
random Canadian things yeah Canadian
Canadians trigger people so I'm close to
the Canadians but yeah you're right it
was a nostalgic time yeah and even for
me like
try not to live in the past right yeah
but like man it's tough some it's so
much such a good time yeah yeah it's not
it's nothing there's nothing wrong with
revisiting it you just you can't be
stuck there exactly yeah me and my
brother are always trying to recreate
the times it's just not doable right so
now you have to keep going keep living
and uh just re just stay focused like
what does Allah want yeah Allah doesn't
want you to go and just reflect on oh I
used to play video games though Allah
actually he says in the Quran you know
get up and warn processarily this is a
time where he was like he was almost
like traumatized because he just
received Revelation right the first time
and the second time Allah imagine Allah
is saying get up and go warn yeah and
he's like on top of that at the night
you're gonna stay up at night and pray
yeah you know you're gonna exalt Allah
now these are the things as Muslims we
need to focus on and it's it's weird
because people think like oh you know
you're just trying to you know get us to
follow some strict routine they don't
know how rewarding it is like yeah for
the people who do it because they they
want to worship Allah they see they know
that it's going to be good for them
Insha'Allah there's so much tranquility
and and praying because you you end you
know you you really just
remove the ego from yourself you lose
the stress from your life yeah it's
crazy because I was at something before
this so I'm late I was a little late but
it was literally all about pray like it
was like this like halaka thing right
and it was all based on prayer and like
this is what you talk about for two
hours so it's crazy that you say this
but like if you look at especially
nowadays the way that most people think
in the west like people are trying to be
stricter with themselves like there's
the workout freaks that will wake up at
like 5 a.m yeah right yeah you're right
and they'll they'll have their life on a
routine and like but when it comes to
praying a religion yeah it's like not
everyone but like right people make that
seem like it's weird but at the same
time they'll be even more dedicated than
than other than Muslims are in like
working out or on like working in
general people get up for work at like 5
a.m and they work non-stop yeah but like
you said like praying and everything
that Islam in all the obligations we
have in the prophet saws
um commanded for or like encouraged to
do is like yeah it's yeah it's for it's
for your relationship with Allah and
like focusing on the next life and stuff
like that but it makes you more
successful in this life praying five
times a day like you have to stop right
you stop what you're doing yeah you go
and you put your face on the floor right
yeah how are you going to get up from
that and have arrogance right and like
think you're important and think that
when you just literally you're putting
your face on the ground what like eight
times in that five minutes right and
like and also that pause right like
let's say you're working or you're at
school whatever you're working right and
you get up I have to go pray you come
back like you're not gonna come back and
you're not gonna like get into some you
start selling alcohol like things that
are you know that were that are are uh
discouraged doing Islam like it's like
that constant it's a constant reminder
that God's watching and that you gotta
be your best person and like yeah so
like it really like it's for us like you
said it's like obviously Allah doesn't
need our worship we all know that but
like although it is an obligation like
there's so many benefits when you sit
and reflect on it of all these things
and like it will make you more
successful in work in school and
everything yeah and the prophet I saw
him like commanded for Hassan right in
Allah commands for Hassan it's like
being the best in everything you do yeah
which includes working out in school and
all these things so yeah that's the
thing that's why it's like a way of life
right and yeah exactly that's an amazing
Point by the way because you mentioned
like these people in like the manosphere
for example they'll be they'll try and
be so disciplined with everything they
do and it's beautiful but I think the
issue is Islam has been delegitimized
recently it's been it's like they people
don't talk about it
um as it should be which is a practical
religion it it doesn't just explain why
you're here how to live life it gives
you rules and guidelines and commands
um for everyone even down to the lowest
common denominator you know it explains
things like even like how to keep
yourself clean how to keep yourself pure
how to interact with people how to
engage in like business transactions
you're not scamming anyone yeah Islam is
so beautiful and practical so when you
look at people in the manosphere they
love the practicality of it if I wake up
and I be disciplined I'm going to have a
good yeah you know mental state I'm
going to be uh successful I'm going to
be able to consistently make money and
you know and all this stuff that I'm not
going to continue to elaborate on
because they they delve into some crazy
things yeah so if a Muslim does that you
know imagine the benefits I mean yeah
I'm sure you felt the benefits of
praying and all that stuff so
alhamdulillah for sure yeah and and and
even in uh that's the thing like there's
so much emphasis nowadays on that on
like what is them like even you see Joe
Rogan talk about all these Muslim
Fighters are so disciplined and like
yeah it's good like they're they're
they're praising the characters as they
see that it comes from Islam yeah but
like it stops there for a lot of people
too where like they don't
like they only like they like that side
and then people will take that and
they'll twist it into other things but
it's just like like you mentioned that's
part of it yeah but what's as important
too is everything it's the point that we
fast obviously there's you know only
Allah knows but Allah says in the Quran
for us to remember Allah and it's so
that we're grateful there's multiple
reasons right but like at the end of the
day what does fasting do for us it makes
us discipline it makes us appreciate
things it makes us do it makes us you
know interact with people in a in a
better way everything about some it's a
community-based religion too like it's
for the betterment of everyone not just
yourself it's like everything every if
you delve into everything even like
even stuff like the the like the funeral
Pro the janaza like yeah if you really
go to one and you just see the way like
everyone comes together around the
family and people are bringing them food
and like the praying like you just see
the way that it it's meant you know
everything has a purpose in Islam
everything everything and even even like
you mentioned dealing with interest and
stuff like that like again it's for the
betterment of society yeah and that
that's what's like uh you know
unfortunately I I can't allow Adam on
the last time Society was actually
following the rules you know any this
country was really living by that the
power system said that when there was
going to be a divide between the Muslims
that basically things you're never going
to get back to that perfect Medina life
you know or in Medina that the way that
Islam was running but you know we're
supposed to take what we can and
implement it but inshallah it is a
communal religion there's it's built for
the betterment of mankind so you're
right there's so many things extract
yeah yeah absolutely and once once
people begin to see that it just changes
some someone's world view you can't
really love liberalism when when you
learn about Islam you can't really love
the you know people being able to do
anything that they want like Islam will
say listen you're not allowed to drink
because it's actual actually harmful to
your body liberalism will say drink as
long as you're not harming someone
else's body you know if you harm
yourself whatever so we live in a
society where they actually don't care
if you harm yourself physically or
mentally or emotionally as long as
you're you're happy but how are you
going to be happy if you're hurting
yourself yeah right Islam prevents all
that so I think once you you legitimize
Islam again and by the way it will it we
will get back to that like almost utopic
Islamic
um lifestyle but that's going to be like
towards the end of times and all that
stuff yeah of course yeah yeah I learned
recently my teacher I was in a class my
teacher said like we are in the end
times like we we are living like
basically in the last day and um he
broke it down with all the evidences and
I I felt like I aged 40 years and now in
that one class I was scary but yeah yeah
no uh
yeah sorry I think what I was you're
right because you're right of course
inshallah when all that happened you
know Islam the World's Gonna Be peaceful
right but I think it would um that
Hadith that I'm referring to is actually
the split between Muslims like the
difference is that yeah that happened
between Muslims and the wars that happen
after prophecies investor and all that
yeah absolutely inshallah we will I
don't know do we want to be there for
them
like do I want to be there do I don't
want to be there yeah
and on the day of judgment we're under
the shade of Allah and so I've got to
always keep learning and you know
keeping ourselves in check inshallah
inshallah you're right and even um even
in different ideologies like people
shift from one extreme to another like
if every other month yeah like it really
just depends what everyone decides is
right at this point in time yeah and
it's just like constant
um flipping and that's what's you know
so unique about Islam and I think a lot
of non-muslims are attracted to about
some is that like it's so Timeless like
and and all the teachings of the Prophet
I said I'm like again there's nothing
that's really everything the prophet
saws commanded for and Todd and the
Quran is like it it still plugs in
perfectly society today so exactly
exactly a lot of people like when they
work out they feed their body you know
when they do work or learn something
they're feeding their mind a lot of
people neglect their soul and that's why
I lost my data you know there's there's
an emphasis on um on on on tiskia or on
purification of the Neffs Allah
literally says he who purifies his nuts
his soul has succeeded and he who fails
to do so has failed imagine you know how
many people
I want to say this referring to you
because you said you have hard uh
I hope I don't well it feels like that
yeah
we'll suffering for you man don't worry
don't worry but a lot of people they
their hearts are closed off and you can
see it on them you know whether whether
they're bitter or they're just
intolerant towards people or whatever it
is you know the process tell them he
basically he taught us that this is a
product of misdeeds and we know that
there's almost even a scientific basis
when you help someone else out you feel
good yeah so what do you think you feel
when you harm somebody yeah whether you
transgress against yourself or other
people that's going to take a toll on
you no but before you mentioned um the
prophet sallam basically prophesying
that there will be a sectarian split
with the ummah and he did the process he
made he made he prayed to Allah for
three things he he asked Allah do not
allow my ummah to be overtaken by like a
Calamity or natural disaster Allah
accepts that and he also made that do
not allow my ummah to be overtaken by
another Nation right and Allah accepted
that and then he said yeah Allah please
do not allow my ummah to split
intersects yeah and Allah said no that's
their test so you see there's a lot of
unfortunately there's even beef online
with different Muslims and stuff and I
wanted your take on that as someone who
is online and literally stopped posting
yeah for the sake of not you know
engaging any of the stuff or anything
that's Haram yeah what do you see or
what do you think when you see this
stuff
yeah man honestly it really like I hate
it I can't stand it uh you know
it's like I'm so conflicted because like
there's so many people that are coming
to Islam so many people that are talking
more about Islam and like the good about
Islam it's spreading right which is
great yeah but with it there's so much
animosity towards other Muslims or other
people and yeah I just think people are
losing the plot to be honest with you
yeah um so like I you know there's a lot
of like
the doubt was seen on YouTube is really
filled with drama unfortunately yeah
anyone that is Muslim knows my problem
is to be honest like
there's just so many kids that don't
really know anything right like not in a
bad way I don't mean this in
disrespectful I don't know anything by
the way like we're all learning always
right but there's so many people who
they're only Islam they get is from like
these creators these creators and all
they see is like
this guy is this guy's ethere this guy
is is uh audio whatever and what what
does that even mean like you don't even
have to worry about that yeah but if
this guy prescribes to that he's a cafe
like you're just like throwing around
kofor yeah and it just like there's just
so many kids they'll watch a video and
they'll start doing doing you know and
it's just crazy like you mentioned like
having a teacher having you know you
know it's not you know that's also the
scary thing is there's a lot of people
that are teaching that probably should
be teaching but like yeah you know the
best thing I think if I want to do is
really learn on your own not get you
know
it's you know sometimes it's hard as
it's entertainment to watch some of
these videos but like it's just like I
feel like a lot of people's Islam is
around some of these controversial
things and yeah I have not been a big
fan to be honest um you know I was I was
watching a lot of specific dawa
YouTubers videos yeah and then I started
noticing like
how often they would call out another
mainstream Imam or something and I was
just like what is like first time I was
like okay that was weird and then I kept
seeing him like what is this like
like what are you what are we doing here
like like even if there's difference of
opinion okay Islam is not afraid of
differences of opinion right there's a
lot of room for differences of opinion
yeah and there's a lot of and there's on
the also on specific things there's zero
room for for differences of opinion
right yeah uh a lot of the a lot of the
arguments seems to be on things that are
have been differed about since the
beginning of Islam yeah that are all
accepted schools of thought schools of
whale you know ways of life yeah and it
just you know there's Fanatics and on I
think they've just done
like Mela reward them for all the good
they've done but man there's been a lot
of harm done by this scene so I'm not a
fan of these call outs and these
refutations and I just think it's you
know
just dividing yeah Islam and dividing
people more and more absolutely all
right you know I'm not a scholar myself
so you know but that's just my
that's just what how I felt and I've
I've you know studied a decent like a
little bit right I started you know in
the last couple years trying to learn a
little more and the more I learned the
more I know I don't know anything but
the more else I know is like you know
let's go to the basics not this random
stuff that we want to focus on so and
that's what's crazy most people don't
even have the basics yeah and they're
just jumping into these like intense
videos of like they can't even like
myself can't even read Arabic and
someone will post a an Arabic text on
the screen and then say this means
you're absolutely wrong and then they'll
throw terms on a person and it's sad
because yeah you have one group who is
Extreme
and then that breaths the same extreme
in the other group yeah of intolerance
and refutation videos and all this stuff
and it's almost like you on one side you
can't really blame them almost because
like they have something they have to
defend themselves right yeah but then
emotion gets involved and people get
angry then they don't make the type of
Defense yeah that they should make they
go on the offense to start attacking the
person so again it's like you see like I
just like and again I don't you know I
have so much to learn but my genuine
question is like do these people when
they're posting these videos some you
know I'm not trying to call out people
but like I would just I would take a
step back if I was I'm like I want what
you were the prophet saws approve of
this video yeah I would doubt that
they'll probably say someone would want
any of this stuff to be going on right
or Allah let alone Allah right yeah like
it's just like I know how it is first
off to be like on YouTube and content
creating like I mentioned when I'm
sitting here I'm making I don't want to
be hypocrite like I'm making videos
making fun of people and I'm not even
realizing I'm how bad it is what I'm
doing right so I get how you can get
carried away
and then I get also how like you know
these people probably have teachers that
are even harsher than them yeah right so
if they're learning from people that are
about that like that's why it's so it's
important to take from the right people
and it's like you know this is just
Allah's test again on on Muslims in
general and on people and themselves but
like um yeah I agree like the more I
went back and like I you know when you
start and you just go to the basics
you're just like
what are the pillars of Iman yeah you're
calling this guy Cafe but what does even
really mean to be a Muslim yeah yeah I
bet you like most Muslims can't answer
yeah what are the what are the like
prerequisites to being a Muslim yeah
there's the the pillars of Iman right
and it's just like
let's forget about you know the
theological differences for now like let
the scholars deal with who need to
discuss it discuss it like unless
someone's saying crazy things like
there's multiple gods or stuff the
propheslam is Alive walking around right
now like okay I get it I like that can
be triggering but
like you said I think everyone should
just we all need to learn the basics
before we worry about
other people a lot of people also think
are
just very obsessed with the concepts of
doing Darwin because yeah you know which
is a good thing but some sometimes
there's you know just people that I
think like dude like let's all learn a
little first before we get into like
wanting to yeah because yeah some people
seem like they just want to debate you
know yeah yeah and and it sucks because
you can really see that on people like I
understand if you have someone who's
being harsh towards Islam sometimes you
need to be a little bit harsh back but
then you have people who are just off
the bat they'll you'll see someone who's
like who seems sincere they wanna learn
about Islam and you know maybe they're a
Christian and those you have Muslims are
like well look at what your scripture
says and they'll just start like yeah
yeah you know going out the person yeah
and there's a lot of uh that's the thing
again like there's certain people I used
to watch then I noticed like as they
grew in popularity yeah a little more
bitter over time yeah it's just like I
don't know like it's I don't know it's
it's weird it really is a weird it's
it's a weird thing that's kind of rising
and now I mean I'm sure you saw between
like popular emabs and YouTubers this is
just like there's just like too much you
know and I just I don't there's no
anyone likes it right like I don't know
it just chill out inshallah you know
just a bump in the road and and we can
all uh learn and spread things the right
way but I get like at the end of the day
like
you know and we all need to focus on
ourselves first and foremost so
absolutely absolutely that that I mean
it's final such a simple point but it's
so beautiful it's like yeah you're
you're looking at the flaws even the
process he said whoever seeks out the
flaws and other people Allah will expose
them for his flaws you know yeah he's
like just focus on yourself you know and
uh this this is not the whole Only God
can judge me kind of thing this is focus
on yourself get your your intentions
straight and if you need to advise
someone do it kindly you know Allah says
he says indeed the Believers are
brothers so make peace with your
brothers and you have people you know
literally basically going to like an
ideological war with people yeah you're
a deviant in your Cafe and you're this
and you're that it's like bro it's crazy
take it easy man yeah it really is good
and obviously I mean most people know
but Hadith about calling someone a cafe
Sam said someone calls him a capital one
of the two is like how do we throw away
that yeah how do you throw around that
word knowing that like that means that
either they got your right the guy's a
cafe or you just call the muslim Cafe
yeah and it's implying right that yeah
none of us need to be doing that anyway
so why do we why do we even feel the
need to be pointing out that disgusting
alhamdulillah
Legend maybe maybe we went a little too
hard on the uh on the bad side like I
said a lot of these Diaries are doing a
lot better than I am for sure let me
reward them I just I just again
when you're putting yourself on that
stage though like you got to be careful
yeah and again I mean I'm talking from
my own experience I have regrets you
know so alhamdulillah alhamdulillah me
as well man me as well you know when you
first get started it's difficult to to
make the right decisions yeah yeah for
sure and sometimes you get pulled down
the wrong path but actually that was
another question I wanted to ask like
did you ever feel like you spoke a
little bit about you know wanting to
basically post what would do good on
YouTube and that stuff but do you ever
feel like it was starting to get to your
head in what sense sorry like like the
fame or basically wanting to get that
dopamine Rush of oh I got x amount of
views on this video I mean definitely
when you're in like when you're posting
every day like you're constantly looking
at your analytics and like yeah but like
never in a sense where like it was gonna
compromise any of my like funny yeah
like no I never
alhamdulillah like it never I was never
like ready to
um
sacrifice my beliefs or anything for
Content or anything money even in
general alhamdulillah a lot of people
I'm sure that definitely happens may
Allah protect us from that I mean it
could happen right I mean honestly like
I I yeah yeah it definitely could happen
I mean it's easy there's other ways too
where like you don't realize that you
may be doing that I mean with content
like again of course I was never gonna
do it like I mentioned like a gambling
video or take a gambling sponsor nothing
like that but like you know with like
The nft Craze that happened in crypto
like sometimes like you know something
is a little bit like that was the first
time I had that feeling to be honest
where I'm looking at something I'm like
typically if I see something it's a gray
area I'm like I'm good right especially
after the experience I first spoke about
where I had all this regret so now I'm
like I'm not going in but like honestly
when that craze happened I'm looking and
like you kind of just convinced yourself
no this isn't Haram but like there was
there was you like like Joe Bradford who
was like
um really into fight like he has I think
like Masters in finance he's someone
that a lot of people go to for finance
he would like break apart certain
contracts Haram stuff like uh that shoot
uh what was that Queen called Shibu you
know like the dog oh yeah whatever it
was called yeah and like you know so
like like I don't know my point is that
like I felt at that point like there
were certain things where like like I
caught myself and I was like okay like
I'm this is like the first time I've
like almost went into like a gray area
and like
you know so like it definitely like
that's what I mean it can happen you
never know so there's things like I had
to like take a step back for sure at
that craze and like yeah I'm sure that
you know there'll be more experiences in
the future but yeah that's why again we
mentioned about praying like when you're
praying every day like these things are
meant for us to
you know reset us yeah and remind us you
know that Allah is watching and that
nothing's worth it and all that stuff
yeah absolutely absolutely have you ever
felt provoked to
respond to any like anti-islamic
rhetoric or any like attacks against
Muslims has that ever enticed you to
want to speak out against it publicly
not really I haven't
I just that's just not really like I
don't
in general I just have never really
cared to like felt the need to respond
to anything publicly
um there's been a lot of like claims
that are made against myself and
faceland over the years yeah there's a
lot of things that people are you know
there's there's some valid things that
people are criticizing and there's a lot
of things that are just so I mean man
you see sometimes like the way that
people get to like a conclusion in their
head and they're so certain what they're
saying and I'm re like I'll read a tweet
yeah like if this happened because of
this and I'm just like if only you knew
the reality yeah but like never do I I
personally like a lot of people do but I
personally never had the urge to like
respond yeah about Islam
um I haven't seen anything crazy yet I
mean I've seen you know you know that
guy true Geordie oh yeah yeah I remember
that whatever he said I don't even
remember but I think I tweeted at him
yeah like there's been a few moments
where I felt the need to tweet like if
it's someone in my community or
something in the Gaming Community yeah
right but again like I would be very
cautious about it because again like I'm
not someone I don't think I'm one who
should be engaging on behalf of Islam
and like I feel like I don't I'm never
gonna go up and debate with anyone right
I'll leave that for the people that know
right the people of knowledge uh but you
know there's been a few moments where
like I've had a little bit I've thrown
out like a tweet or something or even
about like Palestine right yeah but uh
again it's not it's not naturally my the
way like I don't care to respond yeah
yeah unless it's like if I feel any if I
feel like I have to yeah right so like
in the gaming scene that being a Muslim
yeah like if someone close to me says
something like yeah you know I probably
would have to for sure yeah yeah yeah
because you you would be in a position
of Authority or a position of power in
that case exactly if certain things got
to a certain level then I feel like
there's an obligation as a Muslim and
even actually you know a story uh
a couple of my friends in Phase former
phase members some of them are phase
members whatever they went to occupied
Palestine as I'll call it right and uh
they went with friends that they have
yeah and I posted a story
basically like you know because there's
a punch there's a bunch of kids that
follow all of us and they're sending me
their stories like what do you think
about them and they're in Israel like
what and I'm just like I posted a story
and I was like listen I know that I have
so my friends are there and like I mean
I don't even remember what I said but I
posted like a video of the Oxford when I
was there or something I'll just like
like I wish that they understood like
they're having fun when there's kids
tens miles away from them that are being
oppressed and tortured and all these
things and like I got some heat I'm not
gonna lie to you it caused some
commotion internally for sure of course
but honestly at that moment I didn't
care like I know I wasn't doing anything
wrong and I felt like I had to yeah so
if anything popped up in regards to
Islam yeah I would definitely like
alhamdulillah like I'm not afraid of
Linda moving on to something else
exiting whatever I'm doing
um if I you know if I if I have the
obligation to do so so Palestine even
though it's it's it's it's definitely
you know has a a place in like the heart
of Islam you could say it's one of the
Holy sides islamically and Qibla used to
be towards there it's not necessarily um
it's not a religious dispute but no for
Muslims or Jews or anything it's it's
the UN have gone year after year and
reported the the heinous crimes they've
urged Israel many times to like change
their policies and their legislation and
of course you know they they don't so
absolutely it is 100 yeah humanitarian
yeah sorry I threw it in because I'm
Palestinians so I feel the need to speak
on behalf of my people you know what I'm
saying yeah uh it's similar to them yeah
but you're right yeah there's definitely
a difference there but um yeah
so I don't know what the future holds I
guess we'll see right I guess we'll see
if if something comes up and I feel the
need to respond maybe you guys will see
me on social media going crazy I don't
know but uh yeah Phase Apex refutes yeah
if you ever see me please call me yeah
come over and slap me and just say go
back to the classroom and go learn yeah
inshallah my brother Norris what about
Islam really speaks to you
it's hard when you grow up with Islam
it's like all I've ever known right yeah
um but I feel like at the same time
uh
every Muslim has to at some point find
Islam on their own kind of yeah sounds
interesting but as you get older like
the only way you're going to remain a
Believer or like close to Sam is if you
go out of your way to learn more right
so for me
um I just think uh
everything I've ever seen about Islam
right I just felt peaceful to me felt
right to me I think I think when I come
across a non-muslim accepted Islam and
hear the life story
it's very like everything validates it
to me right and this is before really
learning
um more than the hotbas and the youth
groups and all that stuff but to me like
I mean alhamdulillah like I I just
see the beauty in every piece of a stem
yeah like like I mentioned when I go to
janaza I'll just I can't I'll just find
myself thinking like man alhamdulillah
first time because like I I you know I
lost I've only lost like my my grandpa
Leia it's like the only person in my
life that I can remember being old
enough to remember passing away and you
know that feeling like or if you don't
you know the you see people who are
going through a loss and like it's a
tough feeling and like yeah you know
that whole ceremony of the prayer and
all that like the peace it brings you
was just beautiful again like
alhamdulillah like being around so many
successful people and in in gaming and
YouTube living with people and even
being in Los Angeles and just seeing
people like yeah I I genuinely I'm not
saying that I'm not happy about like I I
hope everyone finds inner peace and all
that but like I see the lack of it with
99 of the people yeah
um because when you achieve certain
goals you're kind of like what's the
next right yeah so for me like Islam is
always like I never feel like there's
something missing alhamdulillah right I
always if anything I just have
I have the desire to learn more right
and to understand the Quran more and
learn Arabic better so I can understand
Quran all those things so for me I like
what I love about it it's just like it's
a goal that can never be
reached right because like when you
reach specific goals yeah you just kind
of like sometimes people like they get
like lost like they get they have like a
mental like mental like everything
crashes in their life what am I supposed
to what's the purpose of life so like
having you know it's time for me like
it's a purpose of life it's a way of
life it's it's how so just it life's not
complete without it yeah so it's like
you know I don't know everything ever so
many experiences of stories from the
sahabi or the prophet saws
whatever it is like everything validates
it even more to me so like I mean it
speaks to me is just the truth of it you
know alhamdulillah like I just cannot
believe how clear it feels yeah right
learning about it yeah
as someone who's kind of like lived both
sides like I grew up in a Muslim family
I was taught like the basics and but I I
unfortunately I hate to say that I never
really I don't want to say I was a
catheter but I never really like cared
much or really believing like I always
believed in Allah and yeah I knew that
there was a prophet named We Believe in
but I didn't really know anything other
than that yeah and once I found a lot
you know I I came to really start
practicing at stem because I saw one
video on YouTube talking about like the
beginning of creation and all that stuff
and then I went to the stories of the
prophets I want the story of the
prophetam and by the end of the theater
I was crying and I like it just it it
changed me yeah it completely changed me
and then when I learned about Islam it's
crazy that the Islam gave me confidence
and nothing else could ever give me like
I can have like 50 pounds of pure muscle
I could be the richest guy in the world
yeah I could be you know whatever as
tall as Anthony over here man you know
but
nothing would make me as confident as as
Islam did yeah I don't know why but the
contentment it gives you yeah is that
you can't find it anywhere else no no
I'm the lie I completely agree well it's
you can't you can't describe it unless
you feel it and again like that's the
thing about everything else like
everything else is limit is limited so
like all these other things whether it's
Health whether it's wealth those can all
be ripped away at any moment right
people can get sick and be bodybuilders
and like within weeks Their Skin and
Bones right and with wealth too the
richest people you know Mike Tyson was a
Muslim right yeah uh you know may Allah
guide him always too but like he had 300
million dollars he lost it all really
like that stuff is that stuff happens
wow but like you said like when your
life is not about material or about the
like again we're supposed to be making
money we're supposed to be in good shape
I need to get in better shape we're
supposed to be doing all these things
yeah but like when it's not the when it
all fuels their main purpose which is
pleasing God being good with your family
obeying your pain and all that stuff
it's like
nothing can beat that so you're right
like and hamda can never be taken away
yeah that's what's beautiful about it
and um I think a lot of us have the same
experience you had where like you grow
up you're a Muslim but like kind of by
name again that's what I'm saying like
like for me if I didn't have friends
that were
more knowledgeable like as I grew up
with friends that were praying and stuff
like they knew a little more than I did
yeah they kind of dragged me more with
them and I learned hamdullah because we
were always around the massaging and
stuff like that yeah so it's like if
you're not seeking the environment or
seeking the knowledge like of course
you're not gonna believe that's what's
like crazy I think it's like it's so
simple again but like
how are you gonna love the prophet Islam
if you don't know anything about him
yeah how are you gonna love God if you
don't know anything about him yeah and
if you just think that he's just making
us do this and that and he's not letting
me do this and that like so I think a
problem for a lot of people is like um
they just kind of write off certain
things like yeah they don't wanna they
don't wanna they don't want to go look
more into like the questions and then it
you know so and I understand for some
people but that's the thing like for
someone who sincerely wants to know more
like you have we have to we have to put
in the effort to okay if I'm not feeling
a connection to God all right let me go
read a little more about God understand
how he describes himself in the Quran
yeah how the prophetam talks about him
you know yeah and uh yeah so it's it's
definitely like a lot of people make it
like
blame a lot of things like people in my
community were bad Muslims so they
pushed me away it's all real but at the
end of the day like let's be real with
ourselves it's on us to to learn you
know yeah absolutely and like it begs
the question if you know those people
were bad yeah why didn't you just look
for what is right why didn't you just
look for what is good in Islam why don't
you just go on your own away from those
people find the good people if they're
bad they have to be good somewhere else
yeah you'll find the good people and
learn what Islam really is yeah um and
you made a beautiful point because a lot
of people they're they almost wait to
feel it yeah to practice it yeah but
you're not going to feel it until you
start practicing it right yeah like
you're not going to
you're not going to feel disciplined
until you start waking up at 5am and
you're not going to feel like you know
praying until you're praying
consistently and you you felt the the
blessing and the reward in it so it's
and that's why it's so difficult because
we don't have we don't live in a
community or society that really
promotes these things they promote the
things that actually kill that desire to
want to be close to Allah unfortunately
and um I think also there's oh
you know there's just social media now
and I mean you know it sounds it sounds
hypocritical with me being someone who's
out there making content But like
everyone feels like they're entitled to
everything right one of those things
being like okay if God's Building oh why
don't I get a sign why don't I get
Revelation and it's just like you know I
think I think that
arrogance is like the biggest like for a
lot of people it's like the biggest
obstacle like we you know that's that's
again we'll go back to praying put your
head on the floor and like realizing
that okay I'm not I'm not saying we're
like worthless and I'm not you know
degrading humans like God Praises humans
in the Quran is the best of creation
like I'm not degrading humans right but
I'm just saying like there's a balance
between thinking that I'm so good that
God needs to come to me right and like
also like I don't know I think that's a
big part for people I think like you
said Society kind of promotes like that
type of that type of thinking that way
of thinking and like you know I don't
know alhamdulillah but uh I think for
sure that like you mentioned like if you
are able to Humble in every way in work
and everything right if you're able to
like let go of like Eric the Neffs like
you mentioned yeah and like your way you
view yourself and you humble yourself a
little bit like yeah you'll get your
answers you know inshallah and you
mentioned before fasting fasting is one
of the things that does that right like
it there are very there's actually a lot
of things things you can do in life that
that
will bring you in a state of reflection
and kind of a a d egoized State a less
arrogant State and arrogance I mean to
set the record straight is the was the
fault of Elise yeah it's why he he fell
from he was imagine he was up with the
angels yeah right he was like basically
like one of the favorites of Allah you
know like he was up there he's favored
over the other gen and then you know his
demise came from that arrogance yeah and
that could be any one of us you know we
could be like at the top the most
respecting the community and then all of
a sudden we just overnight yeah
literally change overnight so may Allah
keep us steadfast and keep us humble you
know anything could change your your
mindset your mentality your health your
wealth like yeah we are so fragile I I
think about this more often than I
should yeah we are insanely like it's
just Skin and Bones you know you know
how fragile this is someone could
probably you know kill me with one of
the tripods over here man Like Anything
could happen it's crazy and and just
like the human body so much can go wrong
yeah in hide that you can't control
either oh that's nice there's just so
much out of our control yeah for this
incapable of even like protecting
ourselves like why do we think we're so
above yeah above worshiping yeah a
Creator and why is it so crazy that
there would be a career I don't know
yeah I agree and again this goes back to
like why I personally feel so blessed to
have Islam just like I don't know how
well I don't know how I would have
survived the last couple years if I
wasn't was me too man like like life in
general is hard for everyone right yeah
everything that comes with whatever you
do especially being Pub like everything
being public online and like all the
problems and like me personally I think
I would have went crazy if I didn't have
Islam yeah and unfortunately like and
I'm not like a lot of my friends and
people have seen like I feel like
they've had some hard times and it's you
know online and it's probably I I think
it's because of lack of like I I that
lack of like purpose or that lack of
like you know what is this all for you
know and like
again it's it's like in some ways you
feel selfish because like it makes
it makes you just like
um like obviously the main goal is to
make Allah happy but like it makes your
life actually better to to pray and to
do all these things and you get more
success from it the prophet sallam he
said in a Hadith
um when he said amazing is the affair of
a Muslim he said when something good
happens to him he's grateful and that's
better for him and when something
difficult happens to him he's patient
and that's better for him but no one
another Hadith he said that Allah when
he loves a person he tests them because
it's actually supposed to want to work
as a purification for them and two it's
gonna Elevate them in the afterlife you
know there's a there will be people who
who had the worst of lives you know
their skin was cut up and like they had
a horrible life and then on the day of
judgment Allah will dip them into Jannah
and then they'll come on they'll be like
yeah I've never seen anything bad in my
life and then the opposite is true
there'll be people who had the most
Blissful elegant wealthy life and then
you know they'll be put in Hellfire for
a second they'll be dipped in taking all
they'll say I've never seen anything
good in my life and also the ups and
downs and all that stuff they're all
both are tests from Allah you know Allah
says in Surah when he tests someone and
gives them wealth and he also May test
someone and he restricts the wealth yeah
it talks about the difference in the
reaction from the people when they get
wealthy like oh Allah has honored me
though when they're tested Allah
restricts all of a sudden they're like
man Allah forsaken me he doesn't like me
anymore yeah yeah that's why I sound so
beautiful man it gives you that
beautiful that perfect mentality by
Allah yeah one of my final questions for
you my man yeah is
what is something you wish people knew
about you I'm the wrong guy to ask this
because honestly I wish nobody knew
anything about me
I honestly like uh I I don't I'm so
Pride like my life is so private right
uh and I don't like I don't
love the it's maybe sounds crazy that
I've been doing YouTube for 12 years
I've been online for 14 years almost
yeah uh so you know I don't really uh
I don't really typically like people
knowing certain things but I mean
honestly like if if you asked me this
two years like it would be being Muslim
and being like being Palestinian and
like that that I'm proud of it and like
you know I I would just want to spread
Islam yeah I don't know if there's
anything that I I that I would
want people to know about me to be
honest other than that I just feel like
I genuinely feel like people
I like I want people for their own sake
yeah to understand what Islam is and to
look into it uh I don't know I don't
know if that's a good I don't know
that's a good answer for you but no I
mean listen it's your answer and that's
the best answer right no one doesn't say
anything else how about you
oh God flipping on you oh my God man
um why are you trying to end I'm having
fun here let's keep going alhamdulillah
uh something I wish people knew about me
I wish people knew I actually like I
genuinely care like I wish people
because a lot of people I don't say a
lot of people don't like me but there
are people a good amount of people with
bad perception of me and I think
I don't want to sound arrogant may Allah
protect me but I think it's because like
I try my best to be balanced in the
middle so when you're in the middle both
extremes are gonna think you're extreme
right when you have people like the red
pill people you know when I speak out
against red pill like all these people
like they lose their mind they call me
like a feminist and like all this stuff
yeah and I'm like I'm just like in the
middle you know and then when I when I
talk against like extreme feminism and
stuff you know people on their side are
calling me some like extreme like red
pill guy and it's like I'm just trying
to you know preach it you're just
following Islam that's why like
I feel you like Anna asks me my opinion
I'm just like I follow stem yeah because
it makes sense everything makes sense to
me and obviously we believe it's
Revelation from God so I don't think I'm
smarter than God I don't think that I
and but at the same time it's not just
Blind Faith like we we have reasons we
have understanding of these things we
don't just have like a you like this you
don't like this like yeah we go beyond
that we understand right so like I feel
you I understand that completely and I
think I think you do a great job
personally masha'allah by like I don't
I've never felt that you swayed one way
or another and also don't succumb to the
pressure of either side and that's why
it's beautiful about Islam it's like a
it's the most balanced path in life but
I guess it's a good thing because I mean
you know we didn't really even talk
about phase uh because there's been a
lot of um
drama I guess is it a word but like a
lot of uh this is a lot of we went you
know we went public on the stock market
so like with that has come a lot of
negative and positive you know attention
a lot of negative there's been a lot of
bad unfortunately the last like a year
yeah and I think that's you're right
that one like about caring like there's
so many things
like I mentioned earlier when I see kids
online that are like
like I don't I don't want to actually
respond but definitely in me like
sometimes I'm like dude you don't even
know what you're talking about and I
hate that you think that this is the
reality yeah but that that concept with
some friends like unfortunately
is with you know business that when
business goes and stuff it really can
ruin relationships yeah and like I'm not
saying I had like massive following out
to people but like because of the
structure of phase and the way it was
been ran and stuff like there's been a
lot of things that have like kind of a
lot of assumptions that people have
about myself or other people and like
yeah I think you're right like even no
matter how hard I try to explain like
like I get why you're angry about this
or why you think this but here's the
reality like you know I never feel like
people will understand so for sure like
that yeah that concept and where like
you can never convince someone like
there's certain people and certain
things that like I'm like you know it is
what it is like you you can think that
it's not the truth and uh that's
definitely frustrating yeah especially
with people you care about but uh yeah
yeah
in terms of people close to you I'm you
know not you personally but like close
to anyone
um I can't really speak on that but when
it comes to people online who just see
you unfortunately when you can't
convince someone like that who has
nothing to do with the situation yeah no
you know no money involved in it no
stakes in the game and they just coming
at you with all these accusations and
you can't convince them a lot of the
time
people like us we don't like to to
consider these things because we're not
arrogant people but a lot of the time it
is envy you know Envy exists and it's an
emotional driver for people so if
someone doesn't like you they'll just be
waiting for anything they can use to get
at you I've had people on my DMs bro
well this one guy he yeah he literally
he dumped me he was like on an honestly
can't obviously he's like why are you
such a beta simp and I'm like what the
heck are you talking about man this is
what I'm talking about like this is like
the audience now for like Islam like we
this is not Islam guys like relax
everyone loves these like key words that
they just throw up yeah they just simply
what are we even saying here yeah you're
just relaxing just let's just focus on
what we're gonna focus on is like I'm
sure you have people coming at you all
the time honestly the thing is I don't
even check I never really checked my
comments or anything I'm sure if I did
because like you know I think you guys
even maybe reacted when I posted a
picture going to a model yeah yeah I
think you guys made a clip about it I
think so but when I posted that like
that was a that was right after the
Habib stuff right yeah yeah
and I was like I felt great about it and
I all I saw was positive responses and
then people like smiled agenda and stuff
were making videos and it's like all the
comments are negative and I've seen
people come to me like dude oh I saw
your post and there's so many negative
comments I'm like really I didn't see
any of them like genuinely I never saw
them uh and I guess I don't know I mean
I either I I mean I look at some posts I
never see it maybe I don't notice them
because I just focused on like the
positive they're so many Muslims that
were becoming good things yeah but uh
yeah like I I think my brains Tunes out
that stuff because what are you doing
when you're doing YouTube for that long
yeah you get kind of numb to the to the
hate it is what it's kind of funny
sometimes yeah but I'm sure with you
people get personal because again like
especially when it's another Muslim who
thinks you're deviant or whatever like
yeah it's just like they think like
they're in their head they're convinced
that you're spreading bad like you're
out here the three Muslims like you guys
are just doing bad but you know and it's
just it's crazy but it's the reality
yeah you know I can't I can't imagine
everyone has the things they go through
yeah like you said maybe there's Envy
maybe they have other things in their
life like it's hard to you know to
understand why people get to where
they're at but I mean I just I I don't
think it's worth it half the time to
engage and when I was in high school I
went to a Catholic school so there are
females but it I went from like quiet
didn't really know anything to like
debating people like on a school bus on
a field trip you know it's like I went
completely and maybe it was a little too
much at the time I was a young guy I was
hot-headed but
um you know seeing seeing that that is
online listening to the lectures online
man it was such it was literally like it
might sound cliche but it was like it
was like a light in a dark world man
it's like one year especially when
you're in high school you're you're
working so hard to please everyone make
sure everyone's so happy with you you
know don't make enemies and you're
trying to be popular and
all this stuff trying to fit in man is
such a headache and then Islam comes and
it's like Islam is different from
everything else that they're talking
about but like you don't care you're
like this is what they need to get on
man they need to come to this they need
to see how beneficial it is yeah now
there's definitely
on the daddy thing because I think I
also went a little yeah both I was
annoyed about about all the fitness
everyone's causing it's been happening a
lot of recently specifically yeah but
they all like I mentioned too may Allah
reward them for the good I mean I've
watched a lot of videos like I I've sat
watched hours of live streams from
random guys that maybe I don't
necessarily watch if it was now but I
definitely benefited from a lot of
people I learned a lot you know I got
even some of them made me more confident
in Islam too like there's definitely
that good there it's just it's just yeah
it's I don't think it should be
someone's only source of Islamic
knowledge yeah that's that's what like
stresses me out there's a lot of a lot
yeah I think a lot of kids it's their
only source yeah and that just scares me
because it's like
yeah we should be learning from the
prophet saws directly and from you know
and we have the resources to do that
exactly so you know may Allah guide us
and be on the right Islam always you
know but um and this is something I've
been talking about a lot it might like
my the reason I I learn under my teacher
and like well the reason I respect him
so much is because he's so big on
uniting right this is something that is
so huge in Islam and he's he's always
been and we have a video with him on the
channel inshallah we'll bring him more
yeah sorry what I've never I didn't see
so who you if you don't mind
like one teacher tactically yeah now I
started underwanted but he's the only
chef ever really had like they weren't
super accessible like I've learned under
different people and from different
sources but in terms of like a teacher
that I like I'm dedicated to learn
Andrea it's it's been him alhamdulillah
for the past few years and subhanallah
it's it stood the test of time one with
all everything that's going on and
everyone you know
uh pushing this you're wrong I'm right
this is the this is the correct way this
is the correct method this is the all
this stuff you know
his institution really still the test
town hamdullah and he's been so big on
on uniting everyone you know he never
really pushed anyone away for for their
beliefs you know if he disagreed he
would just explain to them why yeah I
think that's like the number one thing
if you're trying to find someone to
learn from yeah that's how they have to
be yeah you don't want to if you have if
you're going to if you go to class and
someone's like this a group of Muslims
like are all about like you said uniting
and like anybody that I've learned from
it's the same thing like I think it's
actually good to have
uh learn from teachers from different
like you know about certain subjects
it's a good thing to have a mix of
everything
and when you're learning from real
students of knowledge or Scholars like
none of them speak the way that way
against each other yeah they might have
differences of opinions but they welcome
them and they talk about them together
they discuss you know the the filth
behind it the reasons that the evidence
is and all that and then they love you
it's all love and it's all good we're
brothers you know so I think for sure as
long as you know we should be very
careful of who we study under
they obviously need to have the track
record right yeah yeah number one and
number number two again uh you know I
think that's just I think that's where a
lot of these people online have been
spawned from teachers that think like
them yeah that are like very absolutely
about one thought only and we're the
only ones that are right like that's I
just feel like that's scary if you if
you hear that I would be my my uh on me
would be like uh this doesn't feel right
you know so yeah yeah
all the people who are spreading a stem
though other teachers and they they
don't get enough love the the imams and
stuff that I've spent decades studying
yeah and they get undermined by like
General Muslims like it when you sit and
you like really like hear from them and
yeah their experiences it's humbling
yeah yeah
and that's something me and the guys
talked about recently you know we we we
don't just want to be another YouTube
channel that is
you know oh we're on the right path and
you know these people are wrong those
people are wrong we want to unite with
the Muslims we want uh the Muslim
interfighting and all that stuff to stop
so
um you know we used to make like salafi
jokes and all that stuff and you know
we've dropped all that we've dropped it
for the record and um we're just
inshallah calling to you tonight so you
know any Muslim who has like beef or
whatever you want to call it another
Muslim any Muslim you think is deviant
or whatever online uh unless it's it's
like a matter of consensus amongst the
scholars deal with it privately insha
Allah it looks really bad you know
especially to non-muslims when they see
all this fighting with Muslims
themselves it pushes a lot of people
away and inversely the community the
Brotherhood the love the the unity there
it brings a lot of people to Islam
because a lot of people lack that in
life yeah 100 now my real final question
is did you have to wrap up soon
inshallah is what would you give as a
piece of advice to all the young people
who look up to you I think you know I
mean we're speaking a majority Muslim
audience here probably so like like
uh when first and foremost I mean I
appreciate it and I'm not this is not me
trying to be humble well why it's not
but there's you have the right idols and
Role Models right and uh again like
there are people that that are deserving
of that much attention and and I think a
lot of people get lost in the internet
and a lot follow a lot of accounts
basically what I would say is protect
yourself protect the content you take in
yeah protect the people you're around
like be around the right people yeah
consume the right things and focus on
the right things and definitely you know
focus on God first and your parents and
your family don't get distracted from
like it's all fake everything in this
world is well lie I'm not just saying
it's like nothing nothing is important
enough to you know get to let it
overtake your life and uh you know we
can all die at any second so you can't
push things off to life so yeah slowly
but surely what you know work on being
the best version of ourselves and and
making Allah happy first and our parents
and
and then and then achieving our goals
inshallah
grant us good deaths and good lives and
forgive us for our transgressions and
with that being said